[Applause]
so this is pretty obvious hypocrisy
though it it the intended purpose uh you
know of this was to gain awareness and
that definitely happened people are
talking about she basically went to the
met gala which is this um stupid dinner
that the food isn't even good hater you
get to see this exhibit
we're going to get to me being a hater
in a second we get to see this exhibit
as well but basically it's every year
it's basically like a halloween for
famous people and they all dress up in
these stupid outfits and like being
invited is like a status symbol it means
that you're like affecting culture and
essentially what they do is they match
designers with celebs so and then
the designer that anna winter is the uh
person who runs vogue and uh basically
what she does is she'll get all these
designers and then she's like we think
that you would be dressed really well or
you address these people really well
match those people they'll make outfits
for them and boom everybody goes there
and um
aoc ends up going and she's wearing a
dress that says tax the rich on the back
a lot of people have said that it looks
like chick-fil-a writing and
she's going to this event which costs 30
000 per person to go to she's literally
hanging around with the people that
cheat the tax code all the time so some
people might say it's kind of brave it's
like you're a [ __ ] walking into a blood
party like what's up this is what i
believe in i'm out here i think all
y'all should be texts
but she's not there like checking
[ __ ] and she's going where your
taxes where your text is she's kind of
going there cheesing it up and enjoying
the limelight with all these people yeah
smiling in pictures etc so
it looks as if
her messaging could be a little
confusing do you hate people who avoid
taxes because guaranteed everybody there
avoids taxes there's no way 100 percent
or
do you uh do you hate those people or do
you fraternize with them and do you
enjoy them and are those your colleagues
and are those your friends and are you
going to continue to build with those
people
and um what i think is really
interesting about the tax laws that she
would like to implement especially in
new york is rich people are never going
to pay taxes we just have to accept this
i don't know how we don't understand
this because here's the thing in order
to tax people in a normal way there are
other ways you could do it but in a
normal way you have to show income rich
people are rich enough to just not make
money what they'll do is they'll just
put their money back into the business
itself they'll hide their money in stock
they'll hide their money in charities
there's so many other ways to hide your
money to make it look like you're not
making money so who gets punished by
these tax who gets punished by these tax
laws here's who let me just get this one
who gets punched by these tax laws
here's who gets punished
us yes the people who come from either
middle amounts of money or no money and
are starting to make money do you know
how much harder it is for us to ascend
to wealth for us to achieve the
quote-unquote american dream which is
going from nothing to something right
obviously i didn't come from nothing i
came from something but to go to
something amazing something insane it's
so much harder when you're taking 50 60
of our money every single day so what it
does is it just increases
the the gap between the super wealthy
and the people trying to ascend to
wealth you're making it harder for
middle-class people to be super wealthy
you're making it harder for poor people
to ascend to wealthy or even just rich
this is you're [ __ ] the people that
you say you're trying to help and it's
not even touching the people on top in
order to switch the tax code you're
gonna have to do something that's based
on consumption
it's not going to be
based on how much money you make it's
going to have to be based on how much
you consume and i think there maybe are
some countries have done this or they're
suggesting it so basically you get tax
on everything you buy in that fiscal
year
right and this is it's similar the way
that i think that they tax alcohol at uh
at restaurants and stuff like that the
tax gets placed when you purchase the
alcohol okay not how much you're selling
it for instance so essentially a giant
sales tax instead of an income tax
this way they can't avoid taxes by just
spending all the money they make right
or buying assets yeah right because
they're like i'll just buy that asset
and then it depreciates and then i can
write off the depreciation and i find a
way not to pay any taxes these smart
people are smarter than you aoc yeah and
they they hire people that are way
smarter than any [ __ ] politician
they're smarter than you they will
figure out a way around whatever rules
you create and the people that you hire
to create the rules are the dumb people
exactly the smart people were hired by
the rich people to create the rules to
get around that that's the point i was
going to make the irs can pay an
accountant sixty thousand dollars a year
or whatever you're gonna get a sixty
thousand dollar a year tax guy a [ __ ]
billionaire can pay a tax accountant
four hundred and fifty thousand dollars
a year no problem that [ __ ] is
gonna be qualified for that money and
your government [ __ ] is gonna be
qualified for that money so any law that
the government guy implements this rich
accountant is smart enough to figure out
a way around it yeah you will never tax
the rich a sales tax could be a solution
i don't know what it is but i know all
your tax laws they're gonna find a way
around yeah they just are they'll hide
their income they'll figure it out no so
you have it is a tricky thing but don't
punish the people that are trying to
ascend to wealth
right don't punish them and save the
people that you actually are trying to
tax in the first place do you feel
that's her intention
because i don't think that statement is
like ah let's pass something where
only people in i'm referring to the new
tax bills that the house is trying to
pass she's in the house which would tax
new yorkers like the highest up to 66
yeah and she's part of the house yeah so
so it's like that's the bill that she's
supporting
yes and i do think when coming up with
that bill they're not saying oh well we
know the riches of the rich are going to
be able to avoid it we're hoping that we
can start getting the right but it is
the reality of the situation yeah here's
what it's like
she's either
dumb or dumb
she's either dumb for not thinking that
these rich people will find a way out of
it and just not inform them she's just
kind of ignorant to how they avoid the
tax laws which i don't think because
she's a pretty [ __ ] smart girl and
she's like shrewd she goes into those
senate meetings where she got those
senators on the [ __ ] stand she's
grilling their asses with facts nonstop
so i don't think that she's too stupid
to understand how they avoid taxes yeah
i think she's smart enough to have the
research and no right
and
so she's either
so i don't think she's dumb in that
regard and then
this way she's done thinking that the
proposed tax bill will actually find a
way to get any taxes from those rich
people
that they won't find a way around it so
it's like either way so that do nothing
don't punish the middle class
don't punish don't make the middle class
foot the bill
or the upper middle class foot the bill
for those rich people that you actually
want to punish because you keep saying
tax the rich right but like who are you
really talking about you talking about
jeff bezos not paying taxes are you
talking about the guy who makes 125 000
net worth
and real quick and that's a good point
but like if we talk about the top one
percent i think it's people who make
over 250 000 a year which sounds like an
exorbitant money absolutely absorbent
amount of money absolutely 250 000 if
jeff bezos woke up tomorrow making 250
000 he would [ __ ] shoot himself in
the head he'd kill his whole family yeah
250 000 are not the people the irs are
going after matter of fact they don't
even audit you
like they don't actually do like real
audits on you i think unless you're
making like in the millions that's not
saying people can't get audited
everybody can get audited 100
but they're not really looking like
they're going to spend hours and hours
of an accountant's time and money
to get
40 grand from you yeah
yeah or do you think they're gonna spend
hours and hours to get 100 million from
that guy who's hiding money in the
bahamas hiding money in switzerland i
guess you can't do that in switzerland
anymore but like hiding money in panama
that's when they expose like the panama
papers and all that [ __ ] was the guy who
leaked this stuff assange maybe or
whatever like that like those things
that's worth their [ __ ] time to her
credit i think elizabeth warren's tax
plan was like i only want to tax people
making above maybe it was 10 million a
year or 50 million a year something
crazy but yeah this idea of 450 000 a
year yeah you're rich but you're not the
people that are really avoiding taxes
are worth eight nine figures and look at
how stupid they are
i want to tax people making over 10
million a year okay i'll just make sure
i don't make over 10 million dollars a
year yeah i
i will pay
this i will pay oh i made 30 million
this year well 20 million of those
things i put in my charity right that my
son happens to be the ceo of and he gets
paid 19 million dollars a year to bc do
you know what i'm saying like there's so
many and i'm not even any [ __ ] tax
expert or three charities where all my
kids get paid eight million a year now
here's here's where i'm thinking i'm
sure they'll still find a way around it
but if you text net worth yeah the
competition at least where they say hey
jeff bezos is the richest person in the
world then elon musk and there's this
kind of dick swinging that goes on
between these rich people it's not as
public because now they got to hide
their net worth
so billionaire tax do you tax your
shares in the company yeah you can't tax
assets
there's no way to tax net worth once you
sell yeah but that network is
fluctuating like when are you taxing it
at its high like what are you taxing
it's at the end of the year what you get
and you're not getting it because they
exist within the asset you could tax it
even quarterly at it's at a three-month
low yeah and then i guess they could
[ __ ] tank their net worth but then
that's gonna i assume [ __ ] with stock
prices and all that and that's not going
to be worth it that's what i'm saying
it's like listen they're smart people
that have probably tried to solve this
problem i'm not saying you shouldn't do
anything we should do something right
and there's probably a smart person that
knows how to solve it but
this just we're just going to keep
bumping up the taxes and it's going to
affect the same people that they're not
trying to affect doesn't work and just
pisses people off yeah and just for
clarity they're saying this uh tax
proposal won't affect anyone making less
than four hundred thousand
right and i know yes like you said they
keep they can keep moving the goal post
but
it's
and most people make less than that and
that's why most people will support it
right but if you are somebody right now
making let's say 75 000 or you're
somebody making 150 000 you aspire to be
making 400 right and in order for you to
go from 400 to a million they're
basically taking away
your
investment savings so let's say you like
to take 15 of your money right and you
like to invest that every single year
once you hit 400 buy buy investment
buy buy the money that you're going to
put away for your kids buy buy the money
that you're going to put away for your
college or your kids college that
investment money just goes for the
government for them [ __ ] waste it
because they can't find a way to get
money from jeff bezos so i'm just like
why are you punishing the guy who worked
his whole [ __ ] life to get to 400 he
might be able to see a million right or
she might be able to see a million and
you've taken away that investment chunk
that he's been putting away he might be
putting in crypto he might be putting in
whatever these things right you're
taking away to send to the same [ __ ]
people gonna waste the money every
single year anyway the government right
not the best spending not like they do
all bad spending i'm not one of those
people i like the [ __ ] roads i like
the police i like the firemen like i
like the things that we have we have a
lot of great things don't get me wrong
but like
i'm just saying the real money that you
want is the billions that jeff bezos has
the real boogeyman is not the guy making
400 000 a year that's it it's the guy
making 400 million a year and hiding
saying he makes zero hey guys we're
gonna take a break from this exclusive
patreon clip because i got to tell you
guys about the best bongs in the
business and they are brought to you by
freeze pipe okay there's two types of
cannabis smokers out there those who
suffer from burning scratchy throats and
those who smoke a freeze pipe with
freeze pipes freezable glycerin coils
you'll enjoy the colder bigger hits
without the throat burning or intense
coughing freeze pipe just upgraded their
entire bong line for an experience
you've got to smoke to believe in my
hands is their new bong xl featuring an
upgraded base for more filtration and
colder hits no no burning throat or
lungs you're not gonna cough as much
this is the way to smoke you're gonna
smoke weed or cbd or whatever that's the
way to do it this is your piece no
matter what you smoke there's a freeze
pipe piece for you they have plenty you
can go to
thefreezepipe.com and check out their
line of pipes bubblers bongs dab rigs
and more you use the code flagrant and
you're going to save 15 off your first
order okay so go to
thefreezepipe.com all right get yours
today use the code flagrant and save 15
off your first order make sure you go to
thefreezepipe.com to get yours today use
the code flagrant and save 15 off your
first order now let's get back to this
exclusive patreon clip the full episode
can be found at patreon.com
flagrant2 join the [ __ ] arm and and
can he afford it the guy making 400 yeah
he can afford it more than the guy
making 50. i don't want to come from the
guy making 50. i want the guy making 50
to have the opportunity to grow wealth
too leave the money in their hands
because the guy making 50 is probably
going to spend all of his 50 because he
needs to right the guy making 400 is
gonna have more savings you know who's
just gonna have money sit there and do
nothing with it jeff [ __ ] bezos right
elon musk elon musk is like i don't even
want to buy a house oh you don't want to
buy things you don't want to keep the
economy churning you know how economy
works right you need to buy [ __ ] [ __ ]
buddy you know what i mean oh you don't
want material goods isn't that adorable
scrooge yeah
but it's this point that why which is
why i'm not that impressed with aoc's
thing at the mecca like she's
sticking it to people like lil nas x who
like is a recent millionaire like like
grew up not that wealthy like that's not
the guy that when people say tax the
rich they're talking about they're
talking about like rockefeller corporate
billionaires generational wealth that
are using all the accounts to
hide their money it's like the billions
of dollars whereas like the like these
people might pay their taxes like they
might pay some of it like i'm pretty
sure she's talking about those people i
don't think she's no bernie's proposal
is always like amazon's not paying any
taxes even herself she's like amazon's
not paying any taxes so like it's those
it's those giant accounts that aren't
well that's what
they're saying
the message is for them
but people are saying oh it's so brave
that she's going into the den of wealth
yeah she's not going into that i don't
think it's the people she wants attacks
i just think ever brave if you're in a
beautiful dress walking on a red carpet
i just don't find that at the spot for
bravery beautiful the actual carpet of a
[ __ ] king queen
like actual royalty kings and queens and
the [ __ ] plebeians are nowhere to be
found yeah and you're the brave one yeah
that's not brave and i've been trying to
figure out i don't know if i got this
like this this example perfect but i was
thinking why in concrete terms is it so
hypocritical to me so this dinner cost
30 000
for her to go to yeah but she went there
because it could benefit her for a
dinner she ran amazon out of long island
city because it would hurt mom and pop
businesses unscrupulous business tactics
whatever yeah but a lot of people would
have taken those jobs at amazon because
i need to make a living yeah aoc is
willing to forego her morality for a
dinner yeah and an instagram post and a
dress that makes no impact on anything
yeah and she's gonna have a problem with
regular guys who want amazon there
because like yo i need a job yeah so
i've that's where i find the disconnect
and i i don't know if that works but i'm
trying to figure out in concrete terms
what is the hypocrisy because we know
there's hypocrisy to it you just feel it
you just know yeah it's like you could
be selfish with other people's
livelihood but
when it's your opportunity
because i guarantee you whoever funded
her 30 000 ticket does not have
scrupulous business tactics hurts a lot
of mom and pop stores probably doesn't
pay their share of taxes right but
you're cool with that yeah so i can go
to the met gala yeah i'm assuming she
got invited and they're like yeah we'll
sponsor you to go and she was like i
really want to go how can i justify me
going yeah that's why she had her post
before she went yeah i can't i can't
just show up i gotta do something before
she went she tweeted before the haters
get upset which automatically reeks of
guilt yes you already know what you you
[ __ ] up yeah i just think it's like
she doesn't have a way to cut through to
pop culture like she's on all the news
sites he's been on jesus and mural yeah
and that didn't cut through like who
cares what you talk about unless the
heavies are on display like nobody's
paying people you don't know any other
but this is the representation that
everyone is paying like every single
news cycle is covering this team
covering this cnn's covering this
everything's good i give a little i
think i agree with you 100 that a lot of
people are covering it but she is a
lightning rod especially for right-wing
media like no matter what she does yeah
fox is covering it all these other ones
are covering it they're calling her a
communist yeah
and to get the left on board
yeah i guess but like the left loves her
like if she does anything the left is
promoting her oh my god do you see aoc
rip this senator in this court hearing
so i think that she is someone who gets
a lot of buzz i don't think there's
anybody in the democratic party that
gets more
attention than aoc can we can you all
think of anything no maybe biden and
he's a president she probably gets more
news in biden yeah but that's i'm just
saying in politics she gets the most
attention but there are some people that
don't pay attention to politics at all
so now she's tapping into yeah that's
what i think and yeah okay i feel she
does a lot of overperformative [ __ ]
and like
yeah some things i just don't like how
she goes about it but if your focus is
hey i want to try to get this message
out how's where's the biggest billboard
yeah this thing that everybody's paying
attention to what you have on and you're
going to take a picture of it you know
what is the message
the rich i don't i don't like that yeah
i don't necessarily agree with it like i
don't necessarily agree with you
if you get the conversation started now
people talk about i think i think what
you were saying is
is correct she's a girl who grew up in
new york city she's romanced by this
idea of going to the [ __ ] media okay
how can i go to the met gala without
getting all the internet hate yes okay
uh and she found a way to do it that
makes her look brave that makes her look
hip etc the reality that matter is
and
i'll tell you story very quickly
afterwards but like the meg gala i've
always thought it was the stupidest
[ __ ] thing yes before i learned out
what before i learned what it is
and now it's even stupider right
but it's basically value off exclusion
and i'm a complete hypocrite because i
buy sneakers because of value off
exclusion right i'll buy a watch
valuable fashion is valuable fashion is
value off exclusive and so much of life
is value off exclusion bitcoin to a
certain extent there's a limited amount
limited amount so hey let's get it so
my only issue is when there's value off
exclusion and then there's nothing it
provides at all right besides the
exclusion now we have an issue so it's
basically like if you go to a nightclub
they're not letting people in okay fine
but you might get some [ __ ] that night
right you might drink with the boys
party you might talk to a girl go out on
a date there's something that you can
obtain from that experience right you
might have a great [ __ ] dj it might
be a great uh band playing or something
like that right
the med gala is this dinner where the
food is not good
there's an exhibit that you look at that
everybody can look at after you at the
met
so there isn't really anything
exclusionary right the food is not worth
the experience the value is the cachet
of being at the met gallery it's
diamonds it's fraud
there's nothing there and the fact that
these people buy in so much i'm like
this is the stupidest [ __ ] thing so i
asked my girl i was like my girl who is
in fashion for a while um on the
corporate side i was like would you want
to go to the met gala and then i go uh
she's like she's like she's like no nah
no interested in that and i was like oh
okay good she's like why i was like no
they asked me if i wanted to go this
year and i was just like whatever and
she's like they what
and i go uh yeah yeah they just asked me
if i go she's like well why didn't we go
that's good
i go i go well you said you wouldn't
want to go so i don't want to go to
these [ __ ] things she's like oh yeah
it'd be cool to know what it's like
[Laughter]
i do think i think if he gets trashed
the invitation i think you guys i
trashed the thing
yesterday on brilliant and i'm leaving
brilliant idiots and i'm like
i shouldn't have done that not because i
want to go
i do not want to go i have no interest
in going and i think the whole thing is
[ __ ] stupid and you're corralled into
the space and everybody in the space is
like oh everybody here must be cool
right it's like it was like the early
days of soho house i don't know if you
remember going like so house but like
the early days of zoe house like
everybody remember never going to sell
yeah fair enough so it's like everybody
was in there was like well who's who
here yeah this must be really cool and
you could like walk up to anybody talk
to me because everybody there was kind
of like qualified well you must be
accepted in here so it must have been
something right but it was all [ __ ]
it's all fake right but at least there
was like good food or something in there
right the comfy environment etc
but once i found out i was like [ __ ] man
my girl's going to want to go to this
and they're going to ask me to go to
this [ __ ] thing one of these days
yeah and i've said on a podcast that
it's the stupidest [ __ ] thing in the
world and i cannot go without being a
hypocrite yes right i was going to say
it's funny a girl said she didn't want
to go because i got the exact opposite
response yeah stupid but you go
my girl basically said like
i want at least no
it's you know what i'm saying it's one
of those things where it's like nobody's
allowed in she's like yeah the food's
not going to be good all these things
but i want to know the food's not good i
want to know it's a dumb experience and
tying together all the points i think
we've made aoc is our girls
she knows it's stupid but she wanted to
go so she was like let's figure out
let's hey let's have this dress let's
have this tweet before we go so you guys
and now i can go enjoy the met guys
in two years you're going to have to
kill crap yeah just all over my
shoulders hypocrite all over the city
and i'm saying it right now so everybody
knows
that i will never want to go to this
[ __ ] thing but
i would never want to go to the second
how many men want to go i feel like
every woman is like we're going and the
guy's like [ __ ] [ __ ] hell wants to
go out it's [ __ ] halloween huh
go halloween right yeah but halloween
with famous people i like to go to the
halloween parties that have famous
people at them it's the same [ __ ] i was
a cuck a little bit like he likes a
scene like if there's a set of
chocolates that you wanted to go to
every once in a while i'll put this way
every once in a while charlemagne
reminds me that he's from amongst
quarter south carolina yes
every once in a while like i always look
at charlotte man i'm like you're the
biggest guy on the [ __ ] planet you
could do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do etc and every once in a while he he's
missing greets no no no meaning like
he's romanced by these things like that
he's heard of yeah oh the mecca that
must mean you made it i mean charlemagne
you've got more money than almost
everybody at this [ __ ] party you've
got more success than almost anybody at
this party like you don't need to go to
this part like you're the coolest person
sitting at any table at the met gala in
my opinion right it's just a bunch of
people are dressing wearing real crazy
[ __ ] but they might not be [ __ ]
interesting to talk to right you're the
[ __ ] man but there's a little part of
them that's like
i get to be around famous people yeah
i'm like you're famous yeah you're
successful you're brilliant you've been
there [ __ ] kanye's wyoming ranch
haven't you like
it was like when we did the private jet
we're we're doing a private jet and like
dove was getting all [ __ ] anxious
because we weren't behaving right and
i'm like dove
you don't have to fake it
it's ours
we paid for it we could dress however
the [ __ ] we want yeah you made it here
you know what i mean like i know the
past times you've been on jets you were
a guest so you're like don't [ __ ] this
up
you're the person now yeah
[ __ ] it up
if we walk off that jet and we don't
feel embarrassed about how filthy it
we didn't do is right now oh my god
there better be some rappers on that
[ __ ] thing what is this guy doing
what
pretzels everywhere
you know what i mean sunday's tequila
spilt
come on they gonna know this was an
infamous tour jet next people after we
on that jet [ __ ] this is the most loser
[ __ ] trash left in the jet
oreos
condoms everywhere
[Laughter]
cheez-its
jesus oh i'm saying is sometimes we
gotta do [ __ ] for our girls
but i have no idea you have interest in
going to the [ __ ] mecca i do not want
to at all
at all
i still don't really understand
completely what it is like dinner you
just show up and take pictures dinner
and exhibit you walk on stairs so that's
what it is and then there is an exhibit
there that you can check out the met
afterwards
and there's a um a dinner that you get
you guys have there it is and it's also
a fundraiser and the
donations go to like the people who make
the costumes at the museum because
that's the only
it's not funded so they have to fund
themselves so it is an actual fundraiser
yeah sure why do we
dude
on the activities so stupid yeah yeah
aoc should win this season in the
activities she got all these social
media attention can we do that for the
activists can we do that can we stop
making people run can we stop making
people go to events can we stop making
people do things like it's like do you
care about leukemia
uh yeah
are you willing to run for it oh you
know what i mean do you care about do
you care about cancer research yeah yeah
i do care about cancer would you like to
donate some money would you like to
dress up in a halloween costume and walk
up some stairs in front of people
because that's how i'll give you some
money it's like why are we making people
jump through hoops
in order to be activists or donate money
to causes do you care about the cause
yes then give me your [ __ ] money
because the fundraiser has become a
networking opportunity so again a
fundraiser has become a networking
opportunity that's really what it is
you're not going there for the charity
you're going there for the connection
that you might make
or it's like if you're already going to
donate money why not have a little fun
while doing it
that's what the people look at the runs
and [ __ ] like that it's like hey we have
a little competition along with you
don't know fun to me not running yeah
but okay so you would just donate and
not run but other people like enjoy that
activity and it's like oh [ __ ] i could i
can do this activity i enjoy and with a
good cause attached to it like why not
just run
hey how about this
you don't ever have to run for me to
give you money for leukemia if you came
to me and you're like hey bro can you my
my grandma's leukemia we're trying to
raise some money
here you go here's my money
you don't have to run for it you don't
have to jump you don't have to swim you
don't have to do triathlon you have to
bike you don't got to do nothing you're
already going through enough with your
grandma having leukemia yeah here's the
money here you go here's my donation if
you want to do some running afterwards
please exercise great for your body
great for your mind but
you don't have to do i'm not going
at the finish line
there you go that's what we should do
for those races we should stand at the
finish line and let them collect
you don't get anything to cross the
finish what a time limit yeah you got a
what up people you just watched a clip
from our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.com flagrant two all right peace